Quran, which are most clear. It is haram
to steal. It is haram to commit
adultery. It is haram to take usury.
It is
halal and permissible to eat bread and
to drink water. Salah is obligatory.
Fasting is an obligation, etc. The
oneness of Allah, that none is
rightfully worshipped but Allah. These
things are explicit. They are clear.
Anyone who hears a verse discussing this
in this way will understand it properly.
But then there are other things,
other verses, other parts,
that
take a level of knowledge and experience
to understand
in the way that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam intended, for they are
his words, in the way that Allah Subhana
wa Ta'ala intended they be understood.
And he referred to these two groups of
verses as the explicit and the
general or the ambiguous.
And that the people of knowledge, when
faced with something they do not
understand,
they don't jump to conclusions.
They don't force what makes them
comfortable.
They don't force upon the
situation
an explanation that they fancy.
Rather, their motto is amanna bihi
kullun min indi rabbina.
We believe in anything that is from
Allah.
All of it is from our Lord. If they are
faced with a verse that they don't
understand, a narration that they do not
understand, something they don't see the
wisdom behind immediately, whatever it
is,
they have what is called teslim. They
know their limitations.
And that this is truly a hallmark of
knowledge.
Many of us already know this. Many of us
have heard this before.
As a matter of fact, I have spoken in
detail about this
on this very member.
However, this as well is applicable
to the
actions of Allah
and to the decree of Allah.
Just the Quran
is the words of Allah and his
legislative will.
Likewise, the past is the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And often times the decree of Allah
brings upon us things that make us
uncomfortable. Things that outright
causes pain.
Tragedy, crisis, destruction,
illness, all of these things,
bereavement,
that a person based on his limited
knowledge, his limited foresight,
his limited experience,
will not be able to readily see the
wisdom of Allah in it.
And the truth is with respect to the
decree of Allah,
what Allah decrees upon us,
often times we will
depart from this world
not knowing the real wisdom or the
reason behind what Allah has decreed
upon us at every junction.
There are many things that we will leave
this world not knowing the answer to.
Why has Allah done this? Why did Allah
allow this to happen, etc. Those kinds
of questions that crop up in our minds
when we are faced with an uncomfortable
situation.
Yet, that formula remains the same and
that is
Just all of the Quran comes from
Allah.
And when we are faced with a verse or an
aspect of it that we do not understand,
we refer its knowledge to Allah, yet we
affirm that we believe in it because it
is from Allah and we accept it
wholeheartedly and we implement it
even if we don't understand it.
And the same goes
for the decree of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. The same goes for the
qadar of Allah.
A person has something bad happen to
them
that is not of their earning
even if it is outright oppressive from
another person or a transgression or a
calamity or a tragedy or a crisis.
And a person will not understand the
reason for this.
Yet, the people of knowledge
whom Allah has praised are those who are
able to grasp
if they cannot understand anything, they
can at least understand
their own limitations
and understand that Allah is al-Hakeem.
Allah is ar-Raheem.
Allah is al-Aleem.
He is the all-wise, the all knowing, he
is the all merciful.
And that anything that Allah does or
allows to happen, there is some wisdom
behind it.
Even if we can't readily see it, or we
could say especially if we cannot
identify
what that is.
When the Muslimin left Medina with the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
for the battle of Badr, it was not
supposed to be a battle.
It was supposed to be a caravan that
they took
custody of and returned to Medina.
However, when they arrived there,
what did they find? They found an army
of men who had come for war.
They were armed to the gills
and they
had come from
Mecca with that intention, prepared
for it.
And the caravan was gone.
And the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam was there with 300
and some companions.
very
unarmed. They'd only come with very
small arms, not for war. They didn't
have armor. They had only two and some
narrations one
horse with them.
And so they didn't come for this. A
person may look at the preparation of
that battle and say, "Why would Allah
allow this to happen?"
They were unaware.
The people of Mecca were aware and they
came for that purpose. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
what what do
and I that is
[Silence]
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says to the
[Arabic recitation]
desire
the easy road. You desired the caravan.
Take us to the event, come back, no
harm, no foul. But Allah desires a
higher goal.
And that is to put truth in the
forefront
and to put falsehood in its place.
And so Allah caused these set of
circumstances
expertly.
And had they intended the Battle of Badr
and planned for it, it would not have
come to fruition the way it did when
they had not planned.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says
He said, "If you all had planned for
this,
you would have your your plans would
have fallen through.
However, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
had
his plan and it was driven by his wisdom
and his
sense for justice Subhana Wa Ta'ala, his
desire for justice and his justice.
And so we trust in the names and
attributes
that Allah has told us of himself. We
trust that those are his. We may not
know why this has happened
in spite of how much pain it may cause
us or difficulty,
but what we do know is that Allah is
Allah is Hakim and that is enough for
us. And
Robina
Mas Allah
be many
would you do
and you better
feel and
I
am and I would
be feeling and I had
a Hakim Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Muhammad.
Alhamdulillah was
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah.
What I should
be Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah.
What I should be Muhammad Abu
[Arabic recitation]
What should be
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah.
I'm about.
If there is a story that was collected
by Abu Sheikh Rahim Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah Allah.
Which is actually one of these stories
of many Israel.
But it's a story that the scholars of
and the scholars of and the historians
of Islam mentioned
in this vein on occasion.
It's mentioned that one of the prophets
of many Israel
were unsure exactly which prophet it
was.
And it's really inconsequential.
That this prophet was sitting one day
in full view
of a well or a lake
where people would come to draw water
and people would come to
you know
water their horses and livestock and so
forth.
And so he was off in the distance. He
could see everyone that came to this
well.
And it's mentioned in some wordings that
he had asked Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala to
show him a portion of his wisdom with
respect to how he decrees and why he
decrees what he does.
And so he told him to go on this day and
sit at this particular well.
So as he was there
he was sitting and people are coming and
going and he observed one
warrior
a faddist who is a horseman.
This warrior came is the
a sword fighter.
And he came to this well
and you know he was drinking from the
well and his
animal was drinking from the well.
And he dropped
a pouch that had his money in it.
You know this is
this is a little bit unimaginable to us
but
this is back when money had actual value
and so these would be actual gold or
silver coins. They would put them in a
purse in a pouch and they would carry
them.
And so as he was drinking he dropped
this pouch.
Our equivalent of of losing your wallet.
And so, he got on his horse and he left.
As he was sitting there, a shepherd came
with his sheep and with his livestock
and he was watering them and what did he
find but this pouch full of money?
He looks around.
There's no one there.
It's a watering well. How can you hope
to ever find the person that this
belongs to?
He pockets it and he leaves.
Then a third man comes to the well.
A very old man.
An innocent man.
A man that has nothing to do neither
with the pouch nor anything else.
He comes to this well or this lake and
he sits down
and he drinks from it and he's breezing
out by this well.
Only for who to return?
The
warrior.
The sword fighter, the fattest.
Now he's looking for his pouch.
And he is
sure that he lost his pouch here at this
watering well.
So, who does he find? The first person
he finds is
this old man.
"Where's my pouch?" "I don't know what
you're talking about." "Give me my
pouch." "I don't have your pouch." Pulls
his sword, cuts the man's head off.
Then he gets on his horse and leaves.
So, what have we observed here?
We've observed
a man that has nothing to do with
anything
lose his life.
Another man
who has been given
a gift of wealth that he did not earn.
and a third man
who has had his wealth taken away from
him
with,
you know, just a mistake that was made,
an honest mistake.
So, he asks Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
"Allimni.
Teach me the wisdom
behind what I have just witnessed.
Because at first glance, it looks like
the innocent suffer and the guilty
thrive."
However, "Aamanna bihi kullun min indi
rabbina."
And so, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
reveals to him
that
this warrior, this swordsman,
his father
was actually killed by that old man,
way, way back.
Now, he didn't know. He didn't know who
had murdered his father.
And that this warrior's father
had actually stolen that money that that
warrior had from that shepherd's father,
way, way back.
There is a history there.
And so, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
returned the wealth to the rightful
heirs,
and he balanced the scales
of those who have shed blood without
right to do so.
And this is just a very, very small
example, small instance
of the incredibly
sophisticated
and very
delicate scales that are the scales of
justice
and balance that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala keeps in play every single day.
As Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
that Allah
keeps the heavens and the earth in that
balance, and he is never exhausted nor
fatigued by that poise.
[Silence]
Allah wants Islam and Muslims. What do
the shirk of
What do the nifaq
Allah wants to
the muqta
mujahideen in Gaza and Palestine. What
do Lebanon? What do Sudan? What do
Syria? What do every makan? What do the
hell?
What do the rabbal alameen? Allah wants
What do the aduwihem? What do the
aduwihem
the harim? What do the harim? What do
the mansurim?
[Silence]
Stand
shoulder to shoulder, close all of the
gaps.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Brothers and sisters, as-salamu Alaykum.
Just couple of quick announcements.
First,
there's going to be a youth halaqah
after Maghrib, inshallah, tonight and
Sheikh will be the leading
that that halaqah. Please join and
make sure all the children youth is able
to benefit from that.
Also,
we
are going to be enforcing the parking
rules and please park your vehicle
responsibly.
If you see a
yellow orange sticker on it, that means
there may be if the parked vehicle was
parked in the incorrect place or it was
blocking something. So, please make sure
you do not block any driveways
and any of or the ingress egress for the
building. It is a
Tucson fire marshal's requirement also
that we keep complete access throughout
the prayers and after the prayers
so that people can get out in and out
easily. So, if you see any stickers on
your vehicle, that means you may be in
breach and if you want to discuss that,
please contact me, inshallah.
The
Please donate generously on the way out.
Also, the if you remember, we are
ask requesting the diversion of your
Arizona state state taxes. In In other
words, rather than paying to the state
of Arizona, you're going to pay that
credit by paying to the Rahmah Academy.
So, the brother Ahmed Jabari is back
there. He can explain to you if you do
not know what this program is about, but
this is absolutely essential for our
Rahmah Academy that we collect all the
funds we can from this program.
Jazakallah khairan. Please donate
generously on the way out. As-salamu
[Arabic recitation]